[Applause]
happy tuesday everyone
took me three days to write that line
so when things get really bad what's the
first thing that guilty party does they
argue over words remember this classic
blast from the past it depends upon what
the meaning of the word is
yes
as it turned out is
meant your wife is going to lose to
trump in 20 years
didn't see that one coming
there's a joke in there and you know
you're in deep when you're litigating
the definition of the word stranded
most of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home there are no
americans stranded is the white house's
official position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan oh calling you out
[Laughter]
got it so it's just like uh tom hanks
wasn't really stranded on that desert
island
not deserted island
emily desert island
oh
he was just vacationing with a ball that
he talked to
it's creepy and deviant and i'm glad i
didn't know this when gilligan's island
was on tv it would have ruined the whole
plot
because you know they were stranded i
thought peter ducey
left her stranded with that question but
somehow she found her way out
she's baghdad bob with a bob
talk about splitting hairs with a
taliban's machete i wonder if there are
other words we aren't using to her
satisfaction
[Music]
jen you just cut in front of me no i uh
resent you i'm saying that
i
simply um rescheduled your time for the
uh copier
i know i hate her too
ah
this coffee is too hot
first of all i think it's irresponsible
for you to say that uh the coffee is
room uh temperature uh you're just in
the wrong room
oh hold that
[Laughter]
the elevator chopped my arm off i'm just
calling you out for saying that because
uh that's actually called a sudden uh
weight loss so uh
congratulations
i really didn't see that escalating to
that point
but it seems like america is stranded in
more ways than one our military leaders
have allegedly told president that he'll
need to make a decision on whether to
extend the deadline to withdraw forces
from afghanistan because that's the
correct order for an evacuation first
you give up control of the airport then
try to fly everyone home
that's as smart as putting on a helmet
after you were shot out of a cannon
which is what i think happened to joe at
some point in his life
but it shows you the intellectual
constipation that paralyzes our
so-called leaders they extended wars
indefinitely lost lives and millions and
billions of dollars but at least the
paperwork is in order meanwhile the
taliban says they've drawn a red line on
deadlines and you know they mean it it's
not an obama red line in syria which he
enforced as well as the coven rules at
his birthday party
i'm so glad i skipped that
but the taliban issuing orders to us
it's like pouring salt on the wound it's
like after being fired and security
telling you you know no you can't take
your unicorn coffee mug with you that
belongs to the company
but here the taliban got everything
including the coffee mug
did you see all the weaponry they got
that doesn't make them celebrate
christmas nothing will
it's practically impossible to get a
long rifle in new york city to shoot
rats but we just handed over thousands
of rifles and shotguns and howitzers to
a group of radical muslim fighters
they're now on equal footing with a
middle school in chicago
bam
we paid for all of that and some of that
will likely be used against us later so
as we watch this calamity continue to
unfold we should probably stop listening
to our leaders and start listening to
our troops more like this fella here
the more stupid and naive
americans are isn't a testament
to what our war fighters are doing
overseas
the more we take that fight to the enemy
the more stupid and naive
we are as americans because the moment
that we are awoke nation that means
somebody has gotten in
through the wire
done what they need to do
and
wake this nation up but it's the
american warfighter who is out there
keeping our country safe and keeping
america stupid
that's a good point i've said it before
the reason why so many of us me
especially weren't thinking about
afghanistan much it's because i didn't
have to the work was being done by those
brave fighters so i never really had to
consider the threat coming here for a
long time to use an adage we all enjoy
the sausage we just don't want to see
how it's made but now this catastrophic
end shows us the sausage in reverse
and it sucks i take some responsibility
i'm one of millions who got distracted
by the life of non-stop
attention-grabbing entertainment as i
lose myself in the bachelor in peloton
they're unfolded a mess based on decades
of incompetent leadership and corruption
meanwhile our media fussed over pronouns
and toxic masculinity and now the most
toxic males on the planet are locked and
loaded on our dime if only our military
leaders were as woke about countries
like afghanistan as they are about us
remember this moment
i want to understand white rage and i'm
white and i want to understand it
good for you
[Laughter]
but next time maybe prioritize i put
winning wars and protecting americans in
front of understanding white rage
and where's kamala in all this
the caution that if you want to have
christmas toys for your children it
might now be might be the time to start
buying them because the delay may be
many many months
what the hell is she doing
but i guess talking about christmas
makes sense after what we just gave the
taliban
so never mind thousands of american
lives that are at risk your kids are not
going to have that new game boy probably
made in china we don't cut carbon
emissions in this country by another 25
to think our media once thought sarah
palin was a lightweight
kamala makes palin look like a cross
between margaret thatcher and another
margaret thatcher
look i know our leaders are often idiots
but we can't be this stupid anymore and
send our kids to foreign lands for
decades only for it to culminate in this
the least that our inept leaders can do
is not arm the enemy that's like our
cops buying anti-fob blow torches
hammers and getaway cars but you gotta
wonder why kamala would bring up
christmas in august
maybe she knows that in december she'll
be too busy being president
[Applause]
this former criminal defense attorney
worked on more felon briefs than the
prison laundry
outnumbered co-host emily camano
[Music]
he's like a gay bicycle
outspoken
[Applause]
the worst intro ever
outspoken editor chief and spectator
thomas chad with four
sorry
her marriage vows included do not
resuscitate fox's contributor cat tim
and he has more muscles than a seafood
buffet my massive sidekick in the nwa
world television javier taurus
[Music]
good to see you emily hey
hey hey back
you know this is a serious show this
isn't like outnumbered where you can
just show up and you know hang out
dial it in every day um so what do you
make of that did you did you catch uh
biden today making his speecheroo i yes
was it how did you feel about it i don't
want to put words in your mouth but it
was terrible wasn't it
it was terrible and the worst thing i
felt was not surprised i didn't feel
surprised that he buried comments about
afghanistan after a bunch of domestic
policy comments and attacks the
corporations and all of his virtue
signaling to begin with right americans
care about afghanistan we care about it
now it's appalling to me the lack of
perspective he has his tone deafness and
going back to jen saki's comments to
peter ducey about you know calling it
irresponsible to call it stranded no
what is irresponsible is abandoning
americans there abandoning our allies on
the global stage and on the ground there
rep waltz pointed out that no
surrounding no single surrounding
country right now will let americans
have a presence let alone conduct
operations there and the uk was
blindsided it was a nato mission so if
we think that we have any allies that
will back us up that's all faded as well
rep banks pointed out that now the
taliban has more blackhawks than 85 of
the planet
right in addition to 85 billion dollars
worth of equipment and that means al
qaeda is about to have it that means
isis k is about to have it along with
the countless deaths that will be on
walkaway joe's watch and remember this
is against the backdrop of the taliban
saying if we stay there after august
31st to evacuate americans and other
allies that's an extended occupation
that's how they view our presence there
so if biden thinks that there's peace in
our future he's more delusional than we
thought yeah in that speech i feel like
he said meaner stuff about corporations
and did about the taliban
let's not forget the number one terror
threat
is not taliban or isis white guys like
you white guys like me
i don't doubt it sometimes i get a
little ornery if i don't have enough
fiber in the morning i'm an awful awful
beast cat
well now that we're already talking
let's just keep going sure
sure that's how i've worked here so long
no what do you what do you make of this
obsession like that when you talk about
missed priorities about language itself
that like it's you can't use the word
strand well yeah that's definitely
stranded okay and i know that because i
have used the word stranded in far less
different situations have you been
stranded on
um
i don't have to count but um
like if i you know the ubers keep
canceling and i can't find a cab that's
stranded yes
that's stranded even if i'm walking
distance from home what if it reads
stranded right
and it's not like i'm a drama queen or
anything no no no she's really off yeah
she's really really off
not me not you no you're perfectly fine
well adjusted yes
so check
she could comfortably use the word
stranded because if you're isolated but
there's still a chance you could get out
right then you're not exactly stranded
by whatever definition that they want to
use and was it just today you said that
we've moved out tens of thousands of
people in the last couple days what does
that tell you first of all what people
are they americans are they afghanis who
are we moving uh secondly if you're
moving that many people out in two days
that shows that you had absolutely no
plan for this august 31st date i mean
it's horrifying yeah absolutely
horrifying yeah you i i mean
you try to think could it be worse and
perhaps it could be worse but it's still
happening yeah and i'm hoping that this
is like we get through this in in and
with as minimal pain and suffering as
what are you looking at tucker tyler
you know you know what's fun about
victoria
you know what's the fun yeah
um
i could just stare at him and make him
uncomfortable yes it worked it didn't
work he was like huh
i'm a terrorist you're safe bro
you know
when you think about
terrible gape goat joe and i hate to say
that because i work really hard to be
respectful of our president but
what we're seeing is yeah there's this
big uptick and we're getting people out
and got 20 you know why you know why it
wasn't the suits who have no idea what's
going on it's that we have the greatest
military in the universe and they got
together and they started getting people
out right and they're not going to do it
they're not going to do it by the
numbers they're going to start because
that's what our that's what our men and
women do
but
also now
thanks to this policy
we just invented
thousands of hostages right right the
afghans are no longer allowed to go to
the airport do you want to know why
because they need those intellectuals
and those educated and those scientists
those doctors to operate those machines
right that's they see those tomahawks
they see those guided missiles and they
go we don't know how to do this but they
do right so now we're seeing a whole new
group of hostages afghans will no longer
be allowed to go the airport because
they need their families to hold hostage
to make them operate their machines and
teach them how to run their machines so
job well done so
sooner than later
our men and women are going to be seeing
our own missiles and our own bullets
coming our way because guys are going to
help them because they're going to try
to save their families and it's it's
and i'm not i'm not a general but i'm
just looking at it and i it doesn't take
much to add up this is the one thing i
know we got to move on and but it's the
one thing that almost everybody knows
what to do
but the government and i'm wondering
they i mean
if you just look at them with your if
you steal man their argument you must
assume that they thought all of this
through
but they didn't i mean how is that
possible how do we know more than
general milly you know was he too busy
reading anti-racist tracks to figure out
what the hell was i don't think it's on
the generals i think they're not being
heard not being listened and they're
getting directives from people who have
no idea yeah we have a woke
administration so they think if you
offer the taliban free tick tock
platforms they're going to let people go
yeah i mean that's really where they're
thinking at yeah all right up next was
two weeks the end of the slippery slope
australia's lockdowns say no hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else